[Music]
in judging by the cover news I always
judge a book by its cover
alright submitted by nature boys Oh
always in that channel Nature Boy Ric
Flair here's a blonde hair he has [ __ ]
up teeth really ten I thought it was the
guys that go out in like into nature and
like eat stuff I like those nature boys
they're interesting the top viewed
YouTube channel right now is a guy who
doesn't say a [ __ ] word he just puts
his camera up technology yeah that's the
top right now you don't want to talk
that's my [ __ ] that's my homeboy okay
literally goes out in the woods and then
just build huts or [ __ ] my favorite
guys very relaxing and he just makes it
out of rocks and [ __ ] like he's [ __ ]
this [ __ ] put me on to this guy
and I just wait every week for him to
put something but it takes like three
four months like millions of views dude
[ __ ] remember that guy from by
YouTube sort of crying [ __ ] maybe it was
just me that made fun of them alright
anyways a new algorithm can determine
whether or not an Instagram user is
depressed what you can't - yes you can
what you know what I do love though I
like it when girls have a long committed
relationship and then they split with
their boyfriend and you could tell
automatically from their posts because
they post more workout [ __ ] there is
this grandmas then it gets way better
talk about living life and they use
quotes suddenly because they have to
just really show to the world how
they're living the picture what the
cause life is always about what you make
it and then the next picture is I'm in a
bikini
I'm so someone she literally posted a
photo of her like spread legs bikini
like a sexy photo and it said pray for
Houston I'm like excuse
because you go drown in that [ __ ]
dumbass on social media - but that was
just [ __ ] stupid as [ __ ] I can't yeah
so there is this new computer technology
that so they did this experiment with
166 different individuals and about half
of them were recently diagnosed with
depression so they shared a total of
forty three thousand nine hundred and
fifty Instagram photos with the
researchers and the computer guessed it
right when they were guessing who was
actually while that's also a movie
percent of the time hey that's pretty
good this is interesting how do they
know like when they start taking
pictures of them like food like looking
off into the window and [ __ ] and like is
that is that no I saw it they were
saying that the people that were
depressed they tend to post bluer darker
or gray or photos without featuring mini
faces or people that is true why are
they being so nosy o so emo my hair
these like articles of like algorithms
and guinea like things getting smarter
with statistics and stuff I'm thinking
this is like recipe for AI to take over
you're like this is like some [ __ ] that
if computers came in alive and they had
a conscience they will use that data to
outsmart us and they can figure us out
man they know our feelings and stuff now
like I picture this robot coming out to
me out of nowhere right he goes David
you are depress I'm no I'm not you I
said no I'm not
[Laughter]
am I going to kill yourself oh my god
it's okay if the AI was built in China
it'll break in like three years explode
what do you guys think you could tell
your friends and moods by what they post
enough attention I'm gonna [ __ ] only if
I read the caption then I go you're sad
cuz your cat died Oh like when dudes
messaged me like your pictures are
beautiful but I see sadness in those
eyes I'm like [ __ ] you know I'm happy
how do you know these are fake contact
guys but then like they're hoping like
you're like oh oh my god how did you see
I was waiting for someone I just see it
in my eyes take me away and be happy
like [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of my DC
that dude that's like some fourth grade
pickup line all the time now there's all
that [ __ ] I'm gonna be fake accounts
and just start doing an idea and you
never respond no that's not haha you're
crushing their dreams
Gina they could be they're so beautiful
but I said I sank something different
calm down your fedoras showing I think I
think I know what it is you're sad
inside right I knew it's like the is
this food trying to be [ __ ] like a
what do you call that like a like a
mind-reader
mmm besides like oh so sensitive I see
the pain in your eyes like I'm just
hungry
[Laughter]
no one knows you like I know you
I know oh yeah Lupe oh well in this
article too they were saying that they
there's some signs to look for in
yourself and others like if they they
could be depressed like post a picture
of a guy jumping off a building and
saying caption says I'm depressed goals
goals
a post that's depressing and this
person's being depressed what's gonna
happen who the hell is gonna go save
them and make them or like maybe your
friend or your friends are they getting
notified what ya who's who's responsible
with this interest of information like
I'd be sending it to like social service
workers like it don't you know anti
suicide watch group or what thought was
on like the suicide like where we'll
watch your [ __ ] right and somebody comes
up and listen I've been watching this
dude's Instagram and clearly he's
depressed like get the [ __ ] out of my
office
you [ __ ] loser but it's all blue
[ __ ] they live in a white they're at
the beach all the time
it's a [ __ ] film choice alright cuz I
love Blues in my shadows I love Blues in
my shadows I like that look it's like my
[ __ ] like grays and blues I love that
[ __ ]
if you watch me know your whole bedroom
is great ya know comedians are depressed
[ __ ] happy I like those
black-and-white pictures and then they
just accent the red I've been really
digging like um I just learned how to do
it's like turn the cast down you make
your whites appear whiter it's just so
pretty and clean Tyler had like those
fashion [ __ ] they're so good there's
an app apparently that someone one of
the girls that we went to in the event
she showed me she pulled out her phone
and she was like yeah that's app you
just like brush all the white and it
makes it brighter and I've been trying
to find that I got a hair up I'm just be
[ __ ] real and just be pretty like the
way that you already are I can't getting
old it's like when they want that
aesthetic in the whole page to match
[Music]
yeah says the guy that opens starts like
fashion it's like a branding how about
everybody get off my ass right
I remember okay
Oh onion diet yeah he went on all onion
diet oh no this isn't a joke but some
real [ __ ] but it's kind of funny because
he he recently got went to the hospital
because I feel they like stroke or a
heart attack
ah but [ __ ] told us for years I was
like hey go to the hospital because you
look really unhealthy like this is me
telling you you look like healthy and he
goes go to doctor doctor say perfectly
fine and I'm like really cuz you look
like [ __ ] right what is like a heart
attack right and the docs like no he's
he can't eat this he basically can't can
eat [ __ ] anymore it's clearly alive you
know anybody tall onion
what does that mean onion juice great
onion it's a diced onion am I stop
saying onion what is doing I don't know
but he's like that's his concept of a
healthy diet I don't know
interesting stubborn old Asian guy you
know my uncle got diabetes cuz he swore
like man I don't he's like I don't eat
meat so I'm healthy but that will be
like three packs of instant noodles at
night or something he's diagnosed with
diabetes yeah every day I go to their
house I see a brand new watermelon in
the house and that flows not meeting the
date times but you know like midnight
you should when it's at worse for you I
heard that it doesn't really matter what
time of day yeah no my dad's belly
proves shouldn't be eating fruit after
eight this was probably a hamburgers
issue too though
hey you guys want to stock any of us
we'll go ahead down to the description
box below and you can follow us on
Instagram and all kinds of stuff for
more videos
[Music]